does he have black but he's facing mama
jaroff in great form mahmoud of that
last game was a bit of an endgame
masterpiece and now magnus has to pick
himself up go again he knows even a draw
in this game magnus and his fate is no
longer in his own hands so
difficult times for the world champion
manager of meanwhile can relax continue
playing that spoiler role and uh knowing
him he'll go all out for the win anyway
and if momdiaro wins this game he will
win the match it is a must not lose
situation for magnus carlsen and if he
loses this match we could uh we can
say almost 100 certainly he's not going
to win the tournament yeah and actually
there's only one player in this set of
games there's only one player who can
actually win the tournament now and
that's duda if duda draws or wins his
game and pragnanda and carlson lose
dude it's the champion
wow it's uh yeah and also liam outside
chance but
uh yeah there's uh there's a lot of
permutations we'll keep you guys updated
as the results tick in as we see the
evaluation bars change but uh majora do
you think he'll go for a safe approach
and just provoke magnus maybe magnus has
to take some risks i think he has done
with his last move um magnus picking a
very risky opening uh the king's indian
defense a really exciting opening and i
do suggest if you want to learn more
about this there's a chess ball course
out
by our friend english grand master
really strong player gwen jones one of
the strongest players in england and
he's done a brilliant two-part course
and is he is i'm being serious it's of
course i want to get because i love the
kings in the defense i actually managed
to once be cautionary in it when he was
very old but it's it's an exciting
opening he's going for a win and
majora's just like okay i'm not going to
go for the center i'm going to play what
is the pan off i'm going to play this
positional move which kind of stops
black having as much fun as he wants to
magnus lashing out with c5 and uh trying
to complicate the position uh magnus
risking it here i think yeah magnus
definitely risking it actually this is i
was looking at it and i was like this is
very familiar to me and it's actually a
repetition of one of their games during
the tour final
obviously it was shakira who won that
one yeah we remember that tour final
every game went in white's favor and
okay this bishop move very mysterious
but just clearing the way for the white
rook in the corner to slide across two
squares if black's queen gets greedy now
and grabs the pawn in front of her the
black queen can actually grab a pawn but
there will be terrible consequences if i
remember correctly shakarya won that
game very quickly he did and he won it
because magnus grabbed that pawn so
actually taking that pawn is not to be
recommended
magnus should probably just get the king
to safety and castle get black's king to
safety it's the only way now it's the
safest way magnus was rubbing his head
uh maybe just wondering how he's going
to create winning chances in this game
because white's
setup is very very solid
this one has great reputation for white
this type of position is just being hard
to break down not necessarily aggressive
in shaq's style but
magnus just looking up now to the
ceiling he's just
maybe making asking a little prayer or
maybe he's just trying to remember what
he's studied before but wait one second
if magnus draws and liam wins
then liam is the the dangerous customer
for magnus here
liam has the better head-to-head he beat
magnus early in the tournament
yeah i mean so many different uh
scenarios yeah we need we need our
chests for numbers guy don't we yeah to
come to come on and uh clear it up
because there are
percentages
there's so many possibilities here but
you know it's still in magnus's hands
because he can win the next two games
but i feel one thing that for magnus is
they say there's no luck in chess and
that's kind of true because i think you
make your own luck but sometimes you
need the openings you need to get the
positions that
suit what you want to do and to my eyes
this position from magnus's side it
doesn't suit what he wants to do i know
they've had it before um and very clever
choice i feel from mama jaroff a draw is
okay but it's just that space advantage
again that white has and it's very hard
to win against a space advantage when
you don't have a lot of active ideas
so i i feel i feel that the openings are
going very well
for mama jar off in this match a little
bit of luck on his side maybe but he's
creating that luck as well but uh i'm
just checking my database and i can see
that uh
one of our panelists has actually played
this variation with the black pieces and
uh probably has good memories because
you beat andrew greet yes
good friend andrew greet an
international master on the black side
here
he didn't play the best i must say but
uh actually the next couple of moves
very much went in my favor and actually
was very proud of that game i think
pretty much the whole time i played the
top
suggestion of the computer i played just
the best moves throughout the whole game
and i came up with a nice little tactic
later in that one oh did you trap his
queen
yeah actually i won his queen british
championships oh no for ncl four and cl
i was trying to look really clever just
like and say yeah i remember the game
possibly and in that game if i
recall correctly um he already made a
mistake now on the next couple of moves
all the top players study david howe's
game
or every single one of them when david
plays a tournament they're like oh god
oh god we're going to check out david's
games
probably true
actually simon it is
you know a great hungarian grand master
and you know he was like yes david i was
following i like your contortionist
style and i was oh
excellent
you've nearly qualified twice for the
candidates almost almost oh my yes they
must be able to learn a lot from david's
long games yeah you get opening middle
game end game it depends on the style
and also this one for uh for the white
side very much suits my style in general
because it does gear towards a longer
game where it's very safe for white um i
know that game that you've mentioned i
played on the black side that's just
because i'm i try and be a bit flexible
with my openings but
um yeah in general it depends top
players when they want a certain type of
position they look for players who
embody that type of position and
therefore they look at the openings of
those players
meanwhile i was just looking at shaq's
computer and i think he wants to play a
really aggressive move
so not in my style maybe shaq hasn't
looked at this position uh or this exact
position maybe he can't remember what
he'd looked at but i'm [ __ ] i think we're
about to see this move simon oh wow this
would be chaos this is what shaq was
about to click on on the screen he might
change his mind but this pawn push would
just tempt the white queen to capture
two different poison pawns i don't think
the queen can capture either if the
queen captures this pawn the white
knight jumps forward and suddenly whoops
this queen is attacked by the white rook
trouble there for um magnus that's
exactly pretty much how he lost last
time a very similar pattern and
one square one square
similar danger double attack that is
actually the most popular move
and your move has actually been played
before and uh by two players rather cool
names norbert krug
norbert yeah it's not often that you
hear this very old
old-fashioned name yeah
and meanwhile white's pawn stepping
forward just creating this nice little
chain and black developing a knight so
very very solid from both sides i'm
expecting uh
mama jarv just to try and get his knight
out as soon as possible just to get his
king to safety the white king's still
stuck in the middle that's the one
downside for white
yeah
magnus keeps rubbing his face is he a
little frustrated yeah definitely i feel
i mean uh he's just not really getting
the position he he wants out of the
games now this idea this is like a very
aggressive idea and i think he's got to
go for this um and this is a way you can
at least try to complicate things as
davis points out maybe we can just show
what happens if white now played the
quite natural move for castling and the
setup now of black's three pieces after
the bishop develops in and let's say
white plays another quiet move like a3
and now the knight coming in this is
well worth remembering this setup of
these three pieces this is incredibly
dangerous
hence why if we go back to the game if
you get that set up that david's showing
there on the board there's numerous
threats brewing around the white king
and if we go back to the board this is
why uh shaq is not no no no i'm just
going to stop those things from
happening and keep you out if i can yeah
and uh so this pawn push now occupying a
square that the black bishop wanted to
use so no access to this square anymore
magnus just takes a time out but this
one looks weird to me pushing this pawn
forward one square it looks as if if
anything he's trying to trap his own
queen the black queen looks nice and
active but she might well walk into some
pawn pushes later on and she's lacking
squares here the black queen would have
to zoom all the way across to the other
side of the board once more maybe having
to escape using this square um yeah
already it just feels wrong to me for
magnus i think could magnus be losing in
three games here
i mean
pressing forward he's going on the
attack just going for it and this is you
know shaq will enjoy this position as
well there's many creative ideas that uh
he he can try out here and the black
queen has lost so much time yup she's
already moved one two three four times
uh in this game and uh i'm expecting
shaq maybe to attack her with his bishop
or castle the white king this is
slightly weakening for white but not the
end of the world i think white can just
castle here and it's very difficult for
black i do think that the reason uh that
magnus has played this is because he's
he's trying to win this game he's taken
extreme risks and he's saying okay i'm
going to lose loads of time i know my
position is probably bad but i've made
you play this little move on the king's
side this little pawn move and because
you've played that little pawn move if
you castle that way your king's always
going to be weak so i'm going to have
some practical chances but he's losing
more time again the queen is attacked
here david and uh it's got to lose more
time
definitely you know queen has to move to
the edge of the board it's only got
one square was two squares but uh you
know
yeah
i mean yeah it's true that white has
kind of expanded on the right with the
pawns like that queen will just step
forward and actually white's the one
gaining time if anything against this
black pawn yeah but also i just couldn't
say that these those pawns are not
really okay and you'll move on the board
and
it doesn't really feel like a weakness
actually feels like a strength you know
and wow
magnus is trying everything he can it's
a surprising move in balance the
position he's pushed his pawn forward
allowing white to continue the advance
white for sure is going to play this you
don't really want to do anything else
you don't want to allow black to capture
your pawn so why not step forward kick
away the black knight from the center
and you say surprising ivanka because it
looks like black's pieces are just
getting worse and worse yeah but maybe
he had to do that actually maybe you
know it wasn't possible to play the most
natural move which would have been just
defending the pawn with the king because
unfortunately maybe they didn't look
natural to me at all yeah
um but okay uh yeah now this pawn push
has happened and magnus is gonna retreat
with his knight and the problem here
isn't it is that when the black knight
does move which we're gonna wait and see
as you're showing on the analysis board
there is that white has this fantastic
square in the middle of the board and
this is also a risk-free
nice advantage the queens are coming off
you've got no weaknesses as white and
look at that night that night is just
attacking everything you don't even need
to move the knight in there straight
away but it will come into that position
at the right time this is beautiful
black is very cramped and look at magnus
has got his head his
head in his hands there and i think we
can understand why it's not what he
wants here yeah not only is this okay
this is actually happening on the board
this knight is beautiful but this white
bishop as well indirectly threatening a
lot of stuff i mean this just looks
glorious for why this is my ultimate
fancy getting a position like this one
from an opening i mean is it really your
ultimate fantasy
your ultimate chess fantasy exactly yeah
okay i mean it's just beautiful you have
this pawn chain you gain space you have
this beautiful night on the center
i mean what is black doing what are
these pieces doing still asleep black's
pawn structure as well not active
let's go back to the players magnus
already on the back foot and remember if
he loses this one he's got almost no
chance of winning the tournament anymore
yeah
yeah i mean he's he's out of it isn't he
really with everyone else biting his
heels and
he's picked a very risky strategy um by
playing so provocative he could have
played a more solid system uh he's now
how many times he's moved that queen
that's the sixth time he's used this
queen out of how many moves has he
played that's the 16th move so he's
moved it a third of the time you know
over a third of the time and she's ended
up on the square she started the game on
black's move the queen six times and
she's back home sometimes when you when
you're like these games you don't show
them to beginners you just don't show
them because imagine showing a beginner
you're trying to teach chess to oh look
what the world champion's done here he's
moved his queen out early he's moved it
six times and he's put it back again and
it's like don't do that you know but
he's the world champion he does it i
mean i'm query quickly there's like a
story hikaru nakamura uh once brought
his queen out and moved two i remember
and i was teaching at the time in a
school and i went in the kids started
bringing their queen out and i said i
told you not to do that you know you
know it's not a good idea to bring your
queen out in here and then like hikaru
dead air hikari brought his queen out
and moved too and i said
no don't listen to karu and they're like
you know it's just like bad bad advice
so and it's the same here isn't it that
queen's wandering around that's also the
problem with the bond cloud opening one
f three these top ground masses they can
get away with it because they're so good
at chess but at lower levels it will
never work no absolutely not you sounded
like a harry m i was i was doing harry
anfield no that's right yeah just from
yeah that was actually directly harry
enfield here
couldn't remember the name but yeah i
know but uh
well
from a teachings perspective it would be
actually quite instructive if magnus
were to lose just from a teaching
perspective because then you could say
exactly like david says don't do this at
home i mean this comes with uh risks
and uh on the other hand
we've seen it time and time again grand
masters get away with it
yeah and if magnus ends up winning this
game then we might praise him for
provoking mamadourov
lulling him into a false sense of
security uh kind of confusing mamadiraof
magnus does have a couple of minutes
extra on the clock just because he's
played such weird wonderful moves that
manager of has had to pause majora
probably couldn't have guessed anything
that magnus has done so far but
objectively in the grand scheme of
things it's not good for blacken it kind
of reminds me of that game we mentioned
as well the bassman versus olf anderson
game though where um in this very famous
game from hastings about 30 years ago uh
we mentioned in the previous round you
saw that olfansen gained all his space
he came forwards but at some point his
pawns have come a little bit too far
forwards and i'm wondering if white's
pawn on the right-hand side of the board
has done that but a very direct plan
here played in the game yeah mamadourov
is just getting greedy and he wants to
win opponent he's going to win a pawn
that's inevitable now we see his screen
there mama drive looking very calm very
cool and uh we just saw trade of knights
actually on this square and now mamajora
with this last night retreat he's
attacking this pawn with his knight he's
attacking this pawn with his bishop
that's two attacks and the pawn isn't
even defended once so that pawn is
doomed it's dropping off the board on
the next turn no matter what i think
magnus just has to maybe prepare for
that by bringing his bishop or his black
queen i'm just hoping for example that
the white knight captures this pawn
because suddenly
after the black queen moves this knight
is in a pin
and suddenly black is the one conquering
this diagonal with his bishop so this is
what i think magnus just has to do you
have to somehow get your pieces active
this bishop this queen i'm not sure
which order which piece you should move
first but yeah he's about to go down a
pawn i'm expecting if the bishop does
move maybe mamajorov will actually take
this board with his bishop trading
bishops off and uh yes black is one pawn
down now but at least the white king if
it ever castles this side it's going to
be very very open so maybe long term
magnus has some chances against the
white king in the center yeah uh i agree
and also white has to be very careful
with how they retreat the knight retreat
it to the wrong square at your apparel
if you retweet it to be oh no it's fine
my eyesight i forgot about the queen
sitting there on d2
yep so maybe you can re-route it this
way back into the center is that that if
you look at just the king side though
and the structure on the king side you
do see white's pawn all the way up there
and i'm thinking like you know
there's a lot of squares around that
which black might be able to maneuver
into the black king is really really
safe so just later on even even though
this looks like it's going mama jara's
way
there might be some chances on that area
of the board for magnus because majora's
come maybe a little bit too far forwards
well it was the right way to play but
you have to watch out for that yeah it's
provocative that's for sure and uh okay
black brings the queen out so same trick
you can't take this pawn with the white
knight because you lose uh to this
bishop uh coming forward and a pin and
win for black instead white does take
with his own bishop the black rook moves
out of the way of that white bishop and
now i'm expecting shaq i was about to
say i was expecting him to retreat but
i just spotted a really sneaky move you
could even jump into the center with the
white knight hitting the queen because
actually this bishop is poisoned if the
black queen takes this bishop whoops
another knight fork these
royal forks happening all the time
maybe that's possible here for shaq
jumping forward forcing the black queen
to move for the eighth time in the game
and to go back home where she started i
mean
no offense to magnus but if there are
any chess teachers out there
we kind of do want him to lose this
because if he wins this game after just
moving his queen around it's going to be
chaos in the chess scores isn't it i saw
magnus do this i'm going to move my
queen around
it's like no no
he doesn't go for that i was hoping shaq
would do this just to force the black
queen back uh back to her home but uh no
instead in the last position instead of
bringing his knife forward he retreated
the bishop still this idea of hitting
the black queen again
in the air and
okay it's about to happen she's about to
move for the eighth time
uh wow out of how many moves we've got
so that's eight times out of 22 moves so
literally is it
more than a third what does that tell us
about magnus in this game it's not
he's just i think he's just freestyling
he's not really considering long-term
stuff he's just hoping gambling um he's
trying to provoke mamajara but look
where the black queen is now it's still
on a terrible square um it's just eyed
up indirectly by white's bishop and this
is why we always say don't bring your
queen out too early uh it will backfire
the queen is the most valuable piece
anything that challenges her threatens
her she'll have to run away from
yeah um yeah i'm not liking the trend
actually for magnus you know you know we
laughed about it you know hit the queen
moving around
a lot of a lot of times around the board
but uh
whenever we've seen magnus lose it's
because he's wasted a lot of time yeah
i will say like magnus he's got the best
general understanding of everyone
probably in chess history but there are
occasions when
he's tilting when things are not going
in his favor where he just purely
calculates he forgets uh maybe about
king safety we've seen that before in
some games where he neglects his king
safety he forgets that the opponent is
also uh going to play good moves
uh but yeah i mean maybe he'll turn
things around still magnus isn't he's
not out of it yet despite breaking all
the rules yeah being upon down so i'm
just looking at the uh you know
potential things that could happen this
round as you mentioned and uh it looks
like magnus could lose this game uh it
looks like um duda could draw or win
that means if prague
loses we actually have a winner is that
right i think have i worked out right
i'm so confused we need chess by numbers
yeah
liam still has a chance in the rapids
what was right liam against duder
liam beats duda on his birthday okay so
liam could actually pm could be the one
right okay
yeah so if pregnant nanda is on the same
score
but yeah if it's a contest between
pregnant and liam that's it pragmata
wins i just like pandora's
is a contest between yam and magnus and
duda then liam wins everyone but it is
it's definitely very dramatic right now
so magnus carlsen is in a must not lose
situation if he loses this game he loses
the match and he's not going to be the
winner of the tournament and look at the
bar all the way over to sharky outside
and pragnanda as well must not lose
situation against gary he is down by one
point in that match and if he loses that
match it's going to be
over for him as well he's not going to
win the tournament so duda and liam
they are seeing some serious hope right
now about the
duda about to win his match he only
needs a draw in game three here and liam
the bar is all the way over to his side
i mean imagine we've been talking about
prague and carlson as if it was a two
horse race the whole tournament
uh prague leading most of the time
magnus catching him but it could be the
two kind of chasers duda and liam who
end up kind of battling it out for first
place and uh dude it looks likely he'll
kind of get the draw he needs to win the
match in three games
he's just gonna be chill i mean i was
gonna say he's gonna be chilling out
later he looks pretty chilled right now
but if he's chilling out he's just
watching relaxing and the pressure is
all gonna be on his rivals
and uh if if duda
wins
the match against eric
pragnanda is in a must-win situation
right now yep yeah
yeah so it's very tense i mean um
you know going back to the position here
my first thought was oh magnus has made
a bit of progress here because um
maybe he has some targets to attack on
the queen side uh but then looking at a
little bit more it's the real problem
that queen again it's the black queen
the black queen is in a pin
meaning that the knight cannot move if
the knight ever moves you lose your
queen and with the last idea that shaq's
played um he's just aiming to
double up on the open file a very good
idea and there's a lot of pressure on
that night magnus
is trying to defend that knight and shaq
increasing the pressure on that night um
can magnus hold the dark squares
together that is the question that's
what he's trying but look at shaq he's
so confident right now shaq playing
instantly black has a blockade on the
dark squares as simon mentioned but you
can break through this blockade most
likely first you need to remove your
opponent's active pieces and
this black rook looked great inside
white's half of the board so why not
trade it off and okay the black queen is
still on the same diagonal as the white
bishop what is that the ninth time she's
moved now
and um yeah i mean
at the very least
mama jarv can just sit and wait black is
frozen black has nothing to do
at some point you can decide whether to
trade off rooks ideally at some point
you want to mobilize your pawn advantage
white is one point up so these two
should beat this one but they're
difficult to push right now so that's
the dilemma for shaq what to do what to
improve i would be tempted at the right
moment maybe put my king on a light
square first away from black's bishop
but at the right moment you've kind of
dominated this line with white uh with
your rooks at some point you can start
pushing forward and
okay a trade of rooks first yeah i i was
getting a little bit excited because you
can probably guess what i was thinking
about playing ivanka wants to push some
pawns
correct
i was like
and uh get that pawn onto the fifth row
and uh
have you ever been tempted to say that
or accidentally said like
join a game like you're playing because
you just said it there and then like
subconsciously you play a movie like
then you realize like actually not
allowed no i've never
big threat though in the position this
pawn is under fire from white's rook and
white's queen's still looking good for
mahmoud
okay but is he going to sign the
exchange now i mean there's no need no
need there's going to be sacrifice for
bishop
i mean the rook is such a perfect square
it can you know you know it can work
vertically it can work horizontally
across the board i and also
i really really really really really
want to get my plan in the book yeah it
looks good your plan actually too
because the black king has no pieces
around it yeah backing has no pieces so
you could just throw this white pawn
towards it to open it up also a big
threat in the position i think
strategically if black does nothing if
black just waits i'm not sure how for
example with the rook and why could he
even push forward with sorry you can do
it right now yeah i mean sorry students
right but i think prague is about to
lose i think it's uh i think it looks
like he's uh
let me just double check this one on the
board but as as far as i'm seeing um it
is prague is just losing at the moment
so uh so yeah it could we could have a
winner at the end of this round still
wow
that is that means it's probably over
for pragnanda
losing both this game and then the match
to anish giri he will not win the
tournament but what a fight the 16 year
old has given us given us in this
tournament
and shakriyad fighting to win
this game against magnus to decide the
match as well yeah i mean it's sad news
here i just had a peek at the position
and simon is right you know pragnando's
knight is going to be trapped on the
edge of the board there's really no
coming back from that one yeah fair play
to giri though after a difficult
tournament he's uh he's struck back
today and yeah it's just difficult for
prague that it was today that giri
picked his form back up
all right when we see the screen from uh
for marmondyaro thinking for now a
little over a minute is this one of
those critical moments possibly he's
just taking a time out improving the
white bishop actually a big big threat
on the board potentially white's bishop
and white's queen notice how they're on
the same diagonal they're maybe going
towards the black king maybe they're
going to open things up and sacrifice
there but the evaluation bar not
impressed by shaq's last move personally
i thought he looked pretty impressive i
didn't think there was any
downside to this one but maybe the
threats just are imaginary right now
black's king goes to defend some of its
own pawns he's got to do it now he's got
to do it he's got to launch
i mean clearly everything's building up
to this one moment
come on
he's about to retreat his bishop maybe
just a bit of nerves from shakira not
stepping forward on the attack yeah yeah
okay still you know that there is a
threat bishop takes pawn
so okay
i can still see the position being
repeated and my idea coming into
fruition just to show the threat right
now because of the pin on this diagonal
you mentioned bishop takes pawn for
example if black just waits and does
nothing and white can take this pawn
it's not possible to capture the white
bishop because of this pin so that's the
idea it might be worth continuing that
let's say uh in the position black moves
the king rather than allowing that
tactic to occur to get it out the thing
one one thing i sort of saw that white
would love to play is
pushing the pawn on the a file two
squares now i don't think that
tactically works but if you can play
this move the reason you want to play
this is you get a fantastic pass pawn
and we saw mama jaroff use that pawn to
win a little he can't be going for a
draw no is he going for a draw he's
going to do he can't be going for a draw
oh
don't do it let's go back to the players
we could see the position repeat for a
third time if mamadourov puts his white
bishop in the center of the board
he must be getting nervous i don't think
he's gonna repeat you don't have to you
can just move the white king you could
do anything here pour it out there's no
risk as well so pawn up he's got a great
position i mean this this could be
disastrous for him uh and i bet magnus
is plea is there like please please
please just put it back in the middle
now let's have a draw i mean you can't
take the draw here really you just can't
you can't do it
yeah i mean we could even see a
situation where uh magnus if he does
take the draw now wins the next game and
if liam and duda all win we have a
three-way tie for first and they've all
beaten each other
oh my goodness
guess what
i'm just checked checking liam's
position and he is beating jordan van
priest not good news for magnus carlsen
who liam beat earlier in the tournament
look at liam looking focused he's so
good as well he i think has one of the
strongest nerves i've ever seen uh liam
he's just so calm all the time and
magnus he's trying not to betray any
emotions he's got a poker face on but a
draw is on the table if mamojarov wants
it he shouldn't take it of course
manager of but he could ruin magnus's
tournaments chances he's got to play for
the win surely i mean can you push the a
pawn i mean if you can do that then you
play it without thinking maybe it
doesn't work tactically i i guess but
that idea we looked at a minute ago i
mean but still ivanka your idea or just
moving the bishop out of the way
throwing the pawn down the board
attacking the king it's not so much
dangerous there no but unfortunately he
can't put the bishop on the there
he has to move it back again and look
he's lost a lot of times exactly okay
well done
magnus's reaction as well yeah
disappointed yeah he wanted the draw
there you know one time in his life he
actually wanted a draw
yeah that being said the decision did
cost manager of a few minutes and mama
and mamadarov taking a quiet timeout
with the white king has given magnus the
time now to go after white a porn look
at the black rook and queen lining up
against white support on the a2 square
could we see a trade now uh we do see a
trade white's bishop gives itself up for
the black knight how's d6 work this is
this is a question does it work and okay
uh about explosions we have to show this
yeah the game is heating up black is
attacking this pawn with this queen
backed up by the black rook so time is
of the essence and
yes it's a huge moment do you just push
forward with your pawn opening up the
white bishop to attack this rook this is
the most natural move in the position
the question is whether black can just
catch your back ignore you allow the
rook to drop and give a nasty check to
the white king david i think there's an
even stronger move i think you can now
play that move i want to play instead of
going d6 with d6 very strong probably i
think that works but i love
let's just push let's push the airport
he's gone he's gone for the more
tactical idea probably also good but he
had that chance to really really just
have complete control of the position
there it's difficult to spot this pawn
move because instinct-wise you see oh on
password and black is about to promote
to a new queen but white's rook could
have come across and do you skewer and
actually you win a piece here at the
very end black's bishop might drop off
but instead we see the position we did
just show oh wow things are heating up
this pawn pushed forward attacking this
pawn but also attacking the rook in the
corner from white's bishop so black
decided okay he can give up the rook he
captured and after a trade here we see
now this material imbalance it's
actually level pawns but white has a
rook for the black bishop first of all
this check how do you deal with it
can you get a bit crazy and can you
block it with your queen
possibly i guess you can block it with
the queen hoping that this double attack
uh you can just step out of you can
retreat and maintain this pin the
problem is i think maybe by stepping
forward with your queen you just give up
a very important pawn this pawn
and uh i can see this position going
wrong for mag for mama jara the reason i
say that is begin we talked about the
king side white's king side is very weak
and even though you'd exchange up the
bishop to me looks pretty good the pawns
in the middle are active i could
actually see this going wrong just the
fact that you know the rook's not very
good and the white king is the black
king incredibly safe so i'm not
convinced this is you know so clear at
all anymore actually it's definitely a
three result game now
mandiara's still a favorite on the board
but look at the clock he's four minutes
down and magnus he's an end game
magician he can still fight back here so
uh yeah let's see whether the black
queen of black bishop can fight against
white's pieces and it's a win for aneesh
geary against pregnant undying game 3.
that means geary wins the match
zero points for pragnanda who's had a
fantastic tournament
but he's not going to be the winner of
the oslo esports cup but what a
tournament for pragnanda it ends here
though
maybe the pressure over the last few
days got to him a little bit
yeah i mean there there is that as well
but he was also playing some incredible
players and wait one second i just had
to take you back
just happened
is this blindness oh the white rook can
just step forward one square and capture
a black pawn
and he has and magnus look at him oh my
word he's just hallucination he forgot
this pawn was up for grabs could it be a
mouse lip could he have intended to play
the queen because i think look at
shakarya trying to look around the
computer to see what's going on i don't
think it's a mouse slick because he he
as soon as he only when shaq took the
pawn did he react
he's done two of these incredible
blunders he he missed the bishop move
the other day and he's missed the rook
move today i understood earlier in the
event yeah wow i mean this is this is
now game match everything yeah white has
a rook and a pawn for black's bishop now
but the white rook is free that's the
clear thing the white rook has scope
over the whole board it's game over as
you say simon
look what he's done to the bishop as
well dark square bishop well
it's not that's king it's not a great
piece because it's blocked in by its own
pawns
oh no like you said uh simon
it's over
i think that was just a blunder i mean
he blunted horribly against jordan uh
you know kind of forgetting that the
bishop can move all the way to the end
of the board just not seeing it and here
he's missed that the rook can take the
pawn and uh i i i i just yeah quite
quite
quite i'm quite speechless for first
kind in a long time something is up with
the world champion you never see him
blunder like this normally it's happened
a few times this event and look at this
the black queen she did go and grab a
pawn back but she's been distracted and
now it's white's turn to attack the
black king no defenders around it this
is a check and wherever the black king
goes now the white queen is going to
start joining her rook
it's game over any moment now magnus he
might be out of the running for this
tournament yeah he's gonna be devastated
with us i mean uh we know what a champ
he is what a brilliant player and just
how much winning means to him
he's not just going to be devastating
result he's going to be devastated with
his play today it it just hasn't been
him has it no
and uh big threat on the board checkmate
in one move uh the white queen if she
gets time she'll go up on the line and
capture the black f pawn and the black
king is trapped there's no way to save
this game now there's another threat of
the white queen going up to the sixth
rank the black king caught in a
checkmating box in the corner of the
board and uh magnus knows it is
absolutely over there's nothing he can
do zero chance now
oh look at that devastation
just wants to get out there magnus
carlsen is about to lose this match in
three rapid games
and that means he's not going to win the
tournament
yeah imagine the two leaders today
pragnanda and carlson both losing in
three games almost unimaginable
have we ever seen magnus lose in three
games
i mean
i mean i actually i can remember him
losing in three games
but uh i mean it's not live
there we go it's a result he resigns he
offers a handshake to the great shakria
and mamadiaro who played just some
fantastic chance today to win the match
against magnus crossland and shake
everything up